another measure in Washington getting
bipartisan support these days a historic
step to protect marriage equality 12
Republicans joined with every single
Democratic senator to approve
legislation cementing Federal
protections for same-sex and interracial
couples Nicole Killian has this story
the bill as amended has passed and
approve the respect for Marriage Act
a thumbs up from Justin Kettler and Tim
lecker who have been watching the
legislative process play out for weeks
from Dallas we're moving in the right
direction we're in the back the couple
runs a home design business and has been
married since 2017 two years after
celebrating the Supreme Court's Landmark
ruling legalizing same-sex marriage and
that added security and protection and
rights that are inconsequential to so
many people except for us what a great
day Wisconsin senator Tammy Baldwin is
the first openly gay senator in U.S
history and sponsored the legislation to
codify marriage protections into federal
law what does this legislation mean to
you I have in my public life been
fighting for equality fighting for
freedoms and progress and we want to
just make sure we protect that moving
forward the bill does not legalize
same-sex marriage Nationwide but does
require the federal government and
states to recognize legal same sex and
interracial marriages performed in other
states it also includes religious
liberty protections but Republicans were
split this legislation
will put the weighty thumb of government
on the scale
against religious organizations and
individuals lgbtq rights can co-exist
with religious freedom protections the
vote was prompted after the overturning
of Roe vs Wade sparking fears same-sex
marriage rights could be next it
shouldn't be this difficult or this
complicated it's two adults who love
each other fighting for the same rights
the house has already passed a similar
measure and will take up the Senate
version as early as next week there's
been a real push by democrats to try to
get this done now during the lame duck
session before Republicans take over the
House Majority next year which could
make it tougher to pass Nate
Nicole thank you